(audience cheering)
- You are like, every time you come here,
you look so dapper,
so handsome.
- Thank you so much.
You look great, too.
- Well someone, a whole team
of people makes this happen.
I don't look like this in general.
- Well, same.
- No, I feel like you probably
look like this at Target.
- Okay.
- Yeah, you do.
- I appreciate your optimism when it comes
to how I look.
- You totally do probably.
- Thank you.
- But wait, so New Year's just happened.
How do you celebrate New Year's?
- I have absolutely no
expectations for New Year's.
(Kelly laughs)
I have no lists.
- No bar.
- I have no, I call them like at the very,
because what is it?
New year resolutions.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Do you do those?
- No, obviously not.
I've tried.
(audience laughs)
Every year you try.
- Yeah.
- And every year you fail.
Not to be a fatalist.
- Yes.
- But I'm just terrible at them.
- I don't like to say fail.
I like to say just not there yet.
- Right, right, right, right.
Working on it.
We're working on it.
- Working on it, yeah.
- I don't love to work on
things, so I'm just gonna.
- I love working on things.
- You do?
- Yes.
- So, you stick to a list.
- I will stick to list
and it doesn't matter
if it takes a decade,
but I'm still doing it, yeah.
- Okay, great.
- I just like to have, I like goals.
- [Dan] Right.
- I like, yeah.
- Yeah, well, I also now like goals
and want to set them for myself.
- I do.
I don't know why.
I think it gives me
purpose, like to go like,
okay, this is the thing I'm gonna work on.
- I did a thing last
year where I said, okay,
I was gonna walk every day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was gonna add
like an extra five minutes
every time I walked.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
And then 15 days later.
(audience laughs)
- I am on my couch.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's no hiking, there's no nothing.
- Yeah.
- And the shoes are just
sitting by my front door waiting.
- I do like hiking.
You're from the most beautiful place ever.
Canada's so beautiful to hike.
- It is very, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
Didn't do that in Canada either.
- Especially British Columbia, yeah.
Just a hard no.
I love it.
So wait, you and your
dad are both part of,
it's called the Order of Canada, right?
I talked about this with your dad.
- Yeah.
- You're now both a part of it?
- This is a big deal in Canada.
- It is.
It's like, I don't, it's like,
I don't know, am I a knight now?
Like, I don't know what that is.
- I think so, I think so.
- I'm gonna just be knighted,
I guess.
- Yes.
- Is what it comes down to.
You know, it's like a great honor.
I will say, yes, it's
like a tremendous honor.
And I don't wanna
discredit Canada obviously.
- [Kelly] No.
- But my dad has been
on here so many times
that I feel like that
has been the great honor.
And now it's my, on top of like,
I should be wearing my pin, actually.
- Aw, I love your dad.
- He loves you so much.
- Ditto.
I love him so much.
- That is the great honor.
I mean, you know, a country
recognizing you is great,
but being here is also great.
- Ah, I love has anybody,
is there ever in the Order of Canada,
is there like a father-son
or a mother-daughter?
- I actually have no idea.
- I think that you might be
the first, I'm just saying it.
- Let's just say we're the first.
- Let's just say it, yeah.
- I think we should.
- Break the glass ceiling,
I like it, I like it.
- I think you get another
one when that happens.
- I think, yes.
I think you're just a
special, special member.
You get another pin, yes.
- A Guinness record
sort of right at the end
just on the bottom page.